when I was growing up I'd never thought
I'd have the biggest desk or that a desk
would be the main character of an office
no barbarian Ruth has a real community
feel almost like joining a club so we
thought it wouldn't be fun if everyone
considered the one desk as we thought
about and what would this need to be we
wanted the desk to be its own character
your first view into the space is like
people working at a table and only after
that you realize at the table
further down the spaces that is climbing
up and down it could and it moves in
different ways in different heights all
the way through the space the most
affordable way of doing this was to use
plywood we've then covered that all in
one sort of liquid process one paint a
metallic Fleck that was added to that
and an epoxy resin so the space that you
work on is kind of miraculously smooth
and the underside is where you
understand how it all goes together the
archway is in the desk create a lot of
informal gathering meeting spaces for
people the plywood structure also
allowed us to have wall areas where you
could put books and items that actually
really domesticate these spaces
one could say there was inherent risk
because it's never been done before and
we had to go on the journey and hope
that it worked but the overall cost
equation was cheaper than a standard
open plan office the desks that are
still being sold are already about paper
frankly being hard wired with your
computer not having any mobility not
being able to be part of you know
something dynamic who needs a desk
cracking the only needs of this you need
a surface to put things on the whole
world's changing I think that it's time
to utilize those freedoms rather than
resist them
you